quand d'ouvrir bon on ne pensait pas du
procès j'avais
[Musique]
juba soudan depuis la jambe mais jamais
je me sens jamais pleuré jamais non on
était des tenues des âmes 1
[Musique]
oh
un monde même pas moi ils m'ont mis dans
un avion aller en mission un jeu j'en
perds pas l'argent avoue que juste un
peu inquiets après bomba produits suivis
pu mais les collègues but il était là
pour nous remonter à
il rentrait pas l'avion de votre époque
base était quelle personne qui tenterait
pas ses quatre amis qui ne rentrait pas
au début c'était très dur
puis affreux bah non s'il est je viens
doit apporter ma petite histoire un
monde si je pour la recevoir quelques
messages de gens à qui on a sauvé la vie
je serais très heureux
[Musique]